tuberculosis or TB is a disease that's
preventable treatable and even curable
yet it's killing 1.6 million people each
year making it a leading infectious
killer after covert 19.
it's caused by bacteria that spread
through the air and mainly affect the
lungs the pathogen is hard to detect
no country is free of TB but these eight
Nations account for more than two-thirds
of infections and deaths globally
all age groups are at risk but people
with poor immune systems are at a higher
risk like those living with HIV in 2021
nearly 190 000 people died from HIV
associated with TB
the only licensed vaccine the BCG is
more than a hundred years old it's
effective in children but not adults who
account for most Transmissions
TB is treated with antibiotics but its
resistance to drugs is rising
with only seven years left to reach the
World Health organization's end TB
milestone
the race is on for a new and more
effective vaccine